hey everyone here chillin with Brenton
Thwaites from the new show Titans that
you can check out on the DC Universe app
when you first got approached to do the
role of Dick Grayson slash Robin were
you aware that it was this iconic
character was it just like stock comic
book character here's the lines we want
to see how this person reacts to what's
on the page more so than the history of
the comic book care I think it was
important to you know insert some of
that comic book old-school stuff into
the show but also what was interesting
to me is how I react to these new
characters who haven't really seen the
screen before so it was kind of the
whole Titans show that excited me not
just the story of Dick Grayson this is
not your daddy's Dick Grayson this is
not even your uncles or your older
siblings Robin presently new it's it's
nobody you've ever met or roomed with
has experienced the Robin like what we
get with Titans no no they wanted to
create you know a little bit of a darker
Robin and and by that I mean they wanted
to invest in telling the story of what
would it be like to you know live with
getting you know your parents taken from
you at a young age and being taught on
how to brutally solve crime on the
streets of Gotham
so is do you know a little bit more of
like a darker way of you know telling
the PTSD sadness anger frustration of
Dick Grayson we see it was a cop in
Detroit and you went away from whatever
was going on in Gotham with Batman and
what could possibly have gone down
between dick and Bruce that leaves you
to go to Detroit the reason I you know
they created the character to be working
as a detective in Detroit was to show
that I still want that I still you know
I'm craving that crime and that way of
you know solving it in that obsession
with it in a way and Gotham getting out
of Gotham was more related to breaking
the relationship with Batman as opposed
to getting out of the city and we see
later in this series the difference in
the two cities and how things have gone
you know a little bit sideways in Gotham
and when I was with that man do you
think it was just you're tired of having
somebody else looking over you he's
starting to get out and you know
basically wants to start his own thing
you know become his own superhero I
don't have to rely upon
and follow in his wake and kind of live
under his shadow he wants to do his own
thing who's more tired of talking about
that man you a man Oh Grayson or Brenton
with a both dicks today wouldn't say
that at all today maybe Brenton maybe
Brittain
I like I like it cuz you know every
interview I sometimes I hate Batman I'm
on the [ __ ] Batman thing and sometimes I
said you know what actually love Batman
because you know he as a kid he was the
one that I admired that I looked up to
you know who is your Batman oh I think
it was more Keaton yeah especially
recently good man and so I'll ask you
one more question about that yes and it
is the [ __ ] Batman thing because when
you first saw that line written on the
page did you know how you wanted it to
come off well to be honest that was you
know swearing and getting to that you
know stage of the show where the writers
have you know given us swear words to
say and the violence is getting darker
and more heavier was surprising to us
because we had in the first couple of
episodes we tread that path quite
lightly you know they didn't want to
they didn't want to show any of that
stuff and you know in test screenings
and as a result of watching the rushes
that they felt it really needed it and
they had the platform supporting them
and so they kind of went for it and that
was actually a reshoot to try and uplift
and bring a new energy into that fight
scene and when I read it I was like oh
sweet I was yelling at every yen left
right center like I get to say this is
great but you know eventually they'll
like turn it down a bit turn it down a
bit just you know say it like you mean
it you know say it like you know it's
years of frustration and pain and you
know breaking away from that kind of
that brutal relationship to give
everyone f bombs and you know shits here
and there and all these kind of swear
words you become a little desensitized
to it and it doesn't have the meaning
that it would have if it was just that
one poignant moment you know I so I
think throughout this series it was hard
getting that right balance of whence s
where and when not to swear because
people don't walk around going hey what
the [ __ ] sometime today yeah you know I
want to have a [ __ ] car it's [ __ ]
great you know they say it when there
that when they mean it when they're in
stress live would Bruce Wayne is gonna
change your life
ever I admired him at first but I had to
walk away I was becoming too much like
him he was Dick Grayson you're gonna
have some tough days ahead we have real
superheroes that put on a costume and
can kick some ass that are now gonna
have to adjust to this new world that
has these freakish powers that seem
otherworldly how's Robin gonna handle
them he's gonna deal with it and I think
that you know that past life in Gotham
and all those crazy characters that he
has met you know in his teens and
growing up with Batman helped him see
what it is you know and help him see
kind of feeds into that initial instinct
that he knew that Rachael was in trouble
you know all his sources were telling
telling him that you know this is crazy
and nothing's really going on but he
acted on into intuition and kind of
chased her down decided to help protect
it you know and so you know all the
crazy extraterrestrial sci-fi things
that happen in the show that dick sees I
didn't really want to play it like it
was a crazy thing you know I kind of
wanted to play it more or less like it
was not normal but like he felt like he
knew this world exists and he's you know
seeing it for the first time but knew
there's crazy things out there how's the
Robin costume fit it was easy to fight
in it there wasn't really any movement
or stunts that I couldn't do because of
the suit because of my own lack of
physical skills yes but you have a lot
of fight training mean you look like you
you know your way around the dojo for
this one I did learn the bo staff a
little bit you know because Robin fights
with the staff and also just specific
choreograph hand-to-hand combat scenes
so nothing like crazy okay but you could
still kill me with your bare hands yeah
I really wanted to so that plan